[Música]
Estados Unidos Fue a las urnas en unas
esperadas elecciones de medio término en
las que los ciudadanos renovaron los 435
escaños de la cámara de representantes
34 curules en el senado 35 gobernaciones
estatales y cientos de cargos estatales
y locales tanto republicanos como
demócratas esperan a esta hora el
resultado definitivo que les permita
saber cuál de las dos o de los dos
partidos va a controlar cada una de
estas cámaras que componen el congreso
de Estados Unidos de acuerdo con el
recuento de votos una posible ola roja
republicana como lo auguró el ex
presidente Donald Trump no fue posible
el líder también de esta formación
republicana Donald Trump habló del buen
desempeño que estaban teniendo en las
diferentes gobernaciones y en diferentes
condados a lo largo y ancho de la Unión
Americana sin embargo hay que esperar el
recuento de los votos porque Está
avanzando muy lentamente pero eso sí la
noche inicial de estos comicios arrojó
algunos resultados bastante importantes
e interesantes Como por ejemplo la
reelección de ron de santis como
gobernador del estado de Florida por el
partido republicano en sus primeras
declaraciones el gobernador de la
Florida destacó el discurso y el trabajo
que ha hecho a lo largo de estos cuatro
años al frente del Estado del Sol de
Santos es visto por muchos como un
posible candidato a la presidencia de el
país en unos futuros comicios dentro de
la formación conservadora estas fueron
sus palabras tan pronto se dio a conocer
su triunfo en las urnas escuchemos hemos
logrado más de lo que cualquiera
considerado posible Hace cuatro años
pero tenemos tantísimo más por hacer y
solamente he empezado a luchar Dios los
bendiga a todos Muchas gracias a todos
Muchas gracias por una victoria
histórica y avasalladora punto
importante para analizar este tema del
estado de Florida dada la enorme
comunidad hispana que vive allí un
resultado similar tuvo también el lugar
en el estado de Texas donde fue
reelegido Great abbott como gobernador
también por el partido republicano Pues
también estas elecciones tuvieron lugar
en medio de varios temas domésticos
álgidos varios temas que están en la
mente de los estadounidenses por ejemplo
la inflación
récord en la última década en Estados
Unidos la baja popularidad del
presidente Joe biden que está por debajo
del 40%, la economía de Estados Unidos
intentando llegar a vuelo de cruceros
después de ese freno Aunque hubo debido
a la pandemia del covid 19 y a la guerra
en Ucrania y también hay varios debates
al interior de la sociedad
estadounidense debates de larga Data
Como por ejemplo la venta y el porte de
armas migración la interrupción del
embarazo el consumo de drogas entre
otros tantos no podemos dejar de lado lo
que significa una posible nueva
configuración del Congreso de Estados
Unidos para la política exterior del
país es decir en qué va a influir una
nueva conformación de las palabras del
congreso en cuanto a la ayuda a Ucrania
la relación entre Washington y China
Rusia América Latina entre otros temas
de la política exterior qué balance
dejan entonces estas elecciones de medio
término que no provocaron ni olas ni
mareas ni tsunamis está Aparentemente
paridad que hay entre los dos partidos
por lo menos en lo que va ahora del
recuento de los votos que panorama
Entonces nos deja para el gobierno de
Estados Unidos para el presidente Joe
biden y para lo que resta para esos dos
años que le quedan de mandato pues lo
vamos a analizar en este programa del
debate de France 24 para conversar sobre
este tema hemos invitado a
Michelle manat ella es estratega
demócrata ex asesor a principal para
América Latina en el departamento de
estado también es integrante de la junta
directiva del programa de post graduado
en política al management de la
universidad George Washington y también
está con nosotros Julio chilling
estratega republicano politólogo también
director de patria de Martí a los dos
les agradezco por acompañarnos hoy en el
programa yo les recuerdo a nuestros
televidentes que ustedes también hacen
parte de este debate pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Facebook en instagram no se encuentran
como arroba el debate guión bajo f24 le
arrobas antilogo y la etiqueta es
numeral el debate f24 no olviden también
que todos los contenidos de este
programa también los encuentran
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn Pues muy bien
comienzo entonces con Michelle dándole
la bienvenida al programa Gracias para
acompañarnos Michelle hoy para hacer
este análisis de este día después de las
elecciones y lo que ha sucedido después
de esta jornada electoral en Estados
Unidos Cuál es el balance que hace usted
de esta jornada de los resultados no
fueron tan arrolladores como se
esperaban o cuál es el balance que usted
puede hacer
bueno fue una temporada electoral que
todavía no ha terminado muy muy
importante y muy reñido pero
el partido en el poder de la casa blanca
y hasta ahora en el congreso nosotros
los demócratas para nosotros fue una una
noche y muy positiva y yo creo que
también para el país porque vimos en
casi todos los estados funcionamiento
electoral sin violencia sin dificultades
técnicas etcétera Pero tenemos que
reconocer que todavía hay varios varias
contiendas que no se han decidido en
particular bueno en los dos en las dos
en los dos en el senado y en la cámara
no tenemos definición de quién va a
liderar ni en el senado ni en la cámara
porque hay varios que todavía marcha o
proceso de del conteo etcétera lo más
fundamental creo que es lo que va a
pasar en tres estados para definir Quién
va a tener el poder y quién va a liderar
el senado estoy refiriéndome a Nevada a
Arizona y Georgia pero Tuvimos una noche
súper positiva en el estado de
Pensilvania el estado natal del
presidente Joe biden donde ganamos
la puesta el candidato John federman
ganó
y va a ser un próximo senador de
Pensilvania pero también ganamos
gobernación en
ejecutiva porque vamos a tener nuevo
gobernador y nuevo vicegobernador y
procurador general etcétera fue una ola
bastante contundente entonces estos
cargos importantes para los demócratas
una no digo una ola pero una expresión
fuerte azul entonces dónde nos quedamos
ahora en este momento hay mucho todavía
para definir porque no sabemos
exactamente cómo vamos a terminar con
los escaños en la cámara baja Entonces
todavía estamos con unos días o puede
ser un mes más para tener bien claro
cómo va a ser el camino adelante Sí
hemos visto ya algunos avances
significativos Michelle pero todavía
está todo por decir cómo puede ser esa
configuración completa de ese congreso
de Estados Unidos faltan como usted dice
mucho por contar en cuanto a votos y
varios días por delante para poder
definir un panorama un poco más claro
ahora saludo a Julio chilling también
para conocer su opinión La otra cara de
la moneda en este debate conocer Cuál es
el balance que usted hace Julio como
siempre Un gusto saludarlo Bienvenido al
programa cuéntenos Cuál es su balance
Como vi usted del desempeño republicano
y el desempeño democrático general en
Estados Unidos
encantado Santiago de de estar contigo y
con la gran familia de France 24 Mira
hay que poner en esto en contexto los
demócratas subir sufrieron una pérdida o
sea esto es como medir a alguien que le
dieron una golpiza y decir Bueno nada
más que me partieron la cara y una
costilla en vez de la cara todas las
costillas y el brazo o sea fue una
paliza en el sentido que fue una derrota
la cámara baja
la van a van a perder la mayoría Y esto
es muy importante en cuanto a el control
de la agenda de pronto pasa a los
republicanos los comités para que
determinen audiencias
pueden tener que van a tener o sea en la
dinámica
cambia de todo pero sin lugar a duda yo
creo que la la paliza que se esperaba
por muchos es más grande pero esto nos
deja ver una cosa Y de nuevo Hay que
poner algo en contexto el partido
demócrata es un partido es como para
volver la analogía de una pelea es un
partido que tiene más miembros o sea
dentro de los Estados Unidos y hay
algunos demócratas por ejemplo Anthony
de Lucas un legislador
justo Estatal de el estado de
Pennsylvania que murió hace un mes sin
embargo salió electo o sea murió el mes
pasado y salió electo Ah tú sabes tienes
que tener una elección especial o sea
algunos amigos míos pues han hecho el
chiste bueno demócrates Están
acostumbrados a votar por los muertos
pero
la realidad es que hubo sorpresas en la
Florida que siempre ha sido un estado
clave que podía ir demócrata o podía ir
republicano se ha convertido ya en un
sólido bloque republicano el condado
donde yo vivo en Miami Dade creo que es
la primera vez en la historia que la
gana un republicano por un margen
extraordinario también en Palm Beach
otro condado que históricamente ha sido
un bastión del partido demócrata o sea
hemos visto
determinadas
escaños que fueron para los republicanos
en Georgia por ejemplo la negacionista
de elecciones stacrons perdió y perdió
por un margen que hasta a mí me
sorprendió Comparado algo al gobernador
ecamp
queda por contar sin duda y yo creo que
eso pues veremos pero el senado pienso
que los republicanos también van a
obtener la mayoría Julio el capítulo de
Florida lo vamos a analizar en unos
minutos quiero detenerme ahí porque es
interesante lo que ha sucedido en ese
estado y cómo se reco allí las cargas y
la alternancia que hay vamos a
analizarlo más adelante Quiero conocer
lo que dice Michelle Hugo paliza para
los demócratas hubo era esperado este
tipo de resultados Pese a que es todavía
anticipado hablar de una configuración
completa del senado y de la cámara
que le responde usted a Julio hubo
paliza
no no ninguna forma históricamente el
partido en el poder en la casa blanca
sufre bastante en la primera elección de
medio término eso es absolutamente
hemos visto esto año por año por los
últimos 25 años eso pasó a bill Clinton
eso pasó ayer W Bush etcétera entonces
no yo yo no creo y no no acepto este
análisis la verdad es que el país están
hay tanta diversidad de de El electorado
en varios estados que es igual como en
2020 todo depende de estado por estado
porque en 2020 tuvimos que que correr y
logra y ganar el colegio electoral
Entonces yo yo quiero subrayar unas unos
factores un
gobernador o un senador que está en el
poder no que que está postulando para su
futuro cargo para reelegirse es muy
difícil derrotar a una persona que están
en el poder y eso es lo que vimos por
ejemplo en el caso del gobernador Brain
Camp en el en el estado de durazno
Georgia él te tiene tiene un nivel de
aprobación alta siempre fue un un gran
desafío para para
ganar allá porque los factores
cotidianos para para la mayoría de los
votantes Son son más o menos bien están
muy a favor del liderazgo y la el estilo
de gobernación que el Gobernador Camp
pero si podemos ver la situación en los
estados por ejemplo en el estado de
Maryland cerca al Capitolio de
Washington donde yo estoy ahora
en una reflexión de la diversidad y cómo
ha cambiado el estado de Maryland fue
elegido anoche o el primer africano
americano
westmore quien es veterano y él va a
seguir un republicano
porque él tenía mejor como toque mejor
entendimiento de las de las necesidades
prácticas e emocionales
del electorado Entonces yo no veo esto
que fue un palanque por favor y vamos a
ver lo que pasa con la nueva cámara baja
ve usted esta marea roja lenta que se
arma de los republicanos que ha dicho
Incluso el líder Donald Trump en algunas
de las declaraciones que dio ayer al
término del cierre de las urnas allí
desde Mara lago usted nota que puede
haber de pronto alguna ola roja allí en
Estados Unidos o no
Hola roja No yo no veo una ola roja lo
que vemos es que sigue
necesitando el enfoque encima de él el
presidente Donald Trump y el presidente
Donald Trump nunca fue un patriota y ni
ahora es él quiere quiere manipular el
contexto y el ambiente político para
siempre y y es muy importante es como un
cerro grande para el partido republicano
ahora ver y manejar tanto el mensaje
como el contenido o la plataforma frente
a la presencia que sigue de Donald Trump
porque ahora Trump dice que en el 15 de
noviembre en una semana él va a
compartir con el mundo su decisión si se
va a postular otra vez para la
presidencia y Julio qué piensa usted que
le faltó entonces
el transcurso de esa ola roja que
claramente de acuerdo a lo que hemos
visto en los mapas y en los resultados
hasta ahora no se habla de una ola roja
muchos desmienten al ex presidente Trump
será el mismo Trump causante de esa
falta del impulso de la ola roja que
análisis hace usted pero me causa gracia
o sea escuchar por ejemplo mi
contringrante demócrata que tiene que
caer en la bajeza del ataque contra
trombos o sea se ve que padece de ese
síndrome de tropio creo que lo que más
les molesta Es que Trump pues ha traído
al partido
republicano votantes que ellos
consideraban ser parte de la maquinaria
que han controlado como se los negros
estadounidenses como los hispanos cuando
hay precisamente parte de
esa Victoria han sido e hispanos
republicanos mujeres republicanas y en
entiendas donde hubo una competencia
bastante
reñida como en el caso por ejemplo de
Mayra flores que perdió en una
republicana mexicana americana perdió
contra un contrincante demócrata o en
Virginia con la republicana Vega mujer
también o sea conservadora que perdió
contra una demócrata ambos candidatos
demócratas que ganaron se han
distanciado del presidente biden sean
distanciado de la izquierda radical y
reconocen el gran fallo de esta
administración en cuanto a la inflación
en cuanto a la crisis en la frontera sur
el hecho recordemos que el 90% de la
droga que entra a los Estados Unidos que
es el mayor causa de muerte entre
hombres de 18 a 45 años el el la droga
que entra entra por esa frontera Sur
cosa que es un pase de entrada
cualquiera Mira ustedes que donde estén
ya saben que pueden entrar Mientras esté
este gobierno el estado de derecho no se
va y pueden entrar como decir Pepe por
su casa
el nivel de crimen en Nueva York está
tres veces lo que estaba cuando llegó el
presidente Trump el presidente Byron
perdón a la casa blanca de modo de que
los problemas están ahí el hecho de que
la la paliza no haya sido tan severa
porque es ridículo decir bueno Esto es
una victoria Bueno sí la victoria es que
no se perdió tan O sea que no fue tan
brutal la la pérdida y yo soy el primero
en decir que sí yo pensé que iba a haber
una mayor una mayor el logro Pero mira
por ejemplo en Nueva York el demócrata
parte de de era ya una figura pública
establecida Charles
congresista demócrata una alta figura
partido demócrata perdió perdió su
escaño en esa bastión demócrata que es
el estado de Nueva York de modo de que
si han habido
sorpresas en Georgia había un tercer
candidato que él le quitó votos a
errores en ohiol la figura de jd bens
que ganó sobre un demócrata que insistía
que incluso que él estaba imitando a
Trump yo creo que
en esto los los demócratas y cualquier
lectura que se le dé como que esto es un
apoyo
al presidente biden sigue su nivel de
popularidad sigue siendo el 37 38% y 75%
de los estadounidenses coinciden en que
el país está yendo en la dirección
correcta que no haya salido todo que
hayan que hayan sentido más cómodo tal
vez votando en algunos casos por lo
conocido no quiere decir que los
demócratas no tienen
serios problemas Mirando al 20-24 Julio
dejemos En punta el tema de Florida ya
le voy a dar paso quiero hacer una
pregunta de análisis general a sobre la
salud de la democracia en Estados Unidos
qué tan saludable es para estos estados
para las gobernaciones para
estos casos puntuales que ustedes dos
han mencionado Donde ha cambiado de un
partido a otro qué tan saludable es para
Estados Unidos y la polarización que
tiene que haya alternancia entre los
partidos que no se formen estos
bastiones republicanos o bastiones
demócratas de votantes que logran
congregar allí masa sino que hayan Una
alternancia entre los partidos
alternancia del entre los partidos es
una indicación de salud democrática la
verdad y parte de esto también es como
como reaccionó o reaccionaron los
candidatos que perdieron y yo les Les
recomiendo que escuchen las palabras de
varios demócratas que perdieron ayer
inclusive lo que que ha mencionado el mi
colega aquí son Patrick meloni en el
estado de Nueva York Quiero quiero
aclarar que en el caso del distrito de
John Patrick maloney eso no es un
Distrito demócrata o fuerte azul
absolutamente no es muy mixto es más
morada que azul y él Tuvo una gran
sorpresa cuando fue elegido la primera
la primera vez así que siempre un poco
más complicado que como lo analicen los
republica la verdad pero es preocupante
porque todavía no sabemos qué va a pasar
en los Estados fundamentales a la
victoria de 2020 por ejemplo en Arizona
en Arizona donde hay una candidata Kerry
Lake postulante para hacer gobernadora
quien nunca nunca aceptó los resultados
de la elección de 2020 y nunca quería
quería hacer la promesa de que iba ella
a aceptar los resultados oficiales de 20
y 22 así que tenemos este fenómeno que
fue un tema un tema importante en los
medios y para los votantes que fue
negación no de los resultados de 2020 y
aún más importante mencionar que esto ha
tenido un impacto de contagio en el
mundo
absolutamente sin duda por ejemplo en lo
que pasó en Brasil
Julio quiere hacer réplica adelante
julio sí sí a mí me sorprende que mi
colega demócrata traiga colación el tema
del negacionismo Porque steisy todavía
está negando de que las elecciones que
perdió anteriormente sino la última que
fueron
legítimas ella Consideró que fue
fraudulenta los demócratas Si te vas a
la del 2016 muchos de ellos dijeron que
Trump no era el presidente legítimo
negaban que había ganado con la de
manera soberana Hello busquen las
grabaciones de hillary Clinton diciendo
que se robó las elecciones en el año
2000 cuando George W Bush ganó la
presidencia una tercera parte de los
congresistas demócratas una tercera
parte no fueron a la inauguración en
protesta por considerar su presidencia
no legítima
los demócratas han hecho una carrera una
carrera de negar la legitimidad de la
decisión soberana del pueblo cuando
ellos pierden Lo que pasa que ahora
quieren esto y Parece Mentira que
Todavía siguen insistiendo yo les invito
Mira vayan a patria de Martín que ahí
tenemos un video de 15 minutos de las
más altas figuras del partido demócra
incluyendo el presidente Obama negando
la legitimidad de determinadas
elecciones donde ganaron los
republicanos Entonces esto es un insulto
a la inteligencia seguir hablando estas
barrabasadas mira mira en Arizona
ustedes saben quién es la que está
postulándose contra carry Lake la
secretaria de estado ustedes saben quién
cuenta los votos en Arizona la
secretaria de estado las maquinarias
pararon de pronto se rompió el sistema
eso es eso es increíble que los Estados
Unidos esto no pasa ni en El Salvador
por tu vida cómo es posible de pronto se
rompe el sistema no pueden contar más
votos en el precinto más importante del
estado y qué casualidad
dicen que los que si esto es una teoría
de Conspiración cómo es posible primero
que alguien se pueda postular para un
cargo público cuando es quien cuenta los
votos eso es obsceno sin embargo
eso está ocurriendo ha ocurrido y es el
hecho en el estado de Arizona Quiera
Dios de nuevo que
se existe y de hecho han pasado leyes de
integridad del voto más estado para
proteger artimañas que complican el
proceso de la credibilidad al sistema
electoral norteamericano y regularidades
en un estado con Arizona ya las
autoridades llevarán sobre las
autoridades lo que sea necesario para
para poder evidenciar este tipo de
irregularidades en este tipo de conteo
de votos yo avanzo con otros temas que
tengo para analizar que nos deja la
jornada electoral en Estados Unidos y es
el estado de la Florida que queda otra
vez en manos de los republicanos repite
como gobernador ronda santis Michelle
Qué análisis hace usted de Florida que
vuelve y quedan manos republicanas era
un swing State uno de estos estados que
era difícil de entender hacia que
hacia Qué partido iba a optar conforme
avanzaban las elecciones pero ya por
segunda vez consecutiva se mantiene con
un gobernador de corte republicano
bueno Primero quiero contestar a lo que
dijo adelante Pero los dos muy puntual
porque me quedan pocos minutos
de esa información y drama es es
la estrategia de los republicanos de hoy
y es absolutamente incorrecto falso y
paro ahí decir que hillary Clinton no
aceptó los resultados de 2016 Ella hizo
sus comentarios en un hotel en Nueva
York
él hace uno o dos días después aceptó su
derrota eso es con claro no hay no hay
gris eso es blanco y negro Entonces
Lamentablemente el partido republicano
tiene bastante gente como el colega que
solamente utiliza la estrategia de
desinformación y yo Ojalá que en otros
programas en francés 24 tenemos otras
oportunidades de debate con gente más
más serie si puedo decirlo pero la
situación en Florida es muy interesante
para nosotros los demócratas y para los
que nos importa mucho a América Latina
la realidad es que es es fuerte y sin
duda un país rojo ahora con ciertas
distinciones por ejemplo en Orlando
donde ahí fue elegido un joven de 25
años
un miembro de la generación Z que que va
a seguir detrás de valdemings baldeming
fue derrotada por Marco Rubio y yo les
saludo y doy la toda la la felicitación
al senador marco Rubio quien es un
senador que defiende los intereses de
Florida pero la realidad es que con
cuatro años de el gobierno de Florida
hermanos de republicanos han manipulado
a las reglas y las normas del Estado
para garantizar resultados como ayer yo
no sé si queda tiempo suficiente para
tocar este tema pero desde pues hasta el
liderazgo de los condados a casi todos
los cargos en el estado de Florida están
manos de republicanos también el
gobernador santis decidió separarse por
completo de la política de confrontar y
controlar covid y él tuvo esa decisión
poniendo en riesgo vidas de miles y
miles de ciudadanos y residentes de la
Florida entre ellas muchos latinos y
vemos que su opción y su estrategia
tuvo resultados muy políticos para él y
para su partido y él sin duda quiere
postularse para la presidencia 2024 lo
veo usted presidenciable Michelle
que es presidenciable pregunto Sí la
verdad una respuesta corta Sí sí Julio
su comentario su análisis
hay que ver que mi colega tiene la cara
dura al decir que no es negacionista
cuando directamente está en efecto
negando la legitimidad de la victoria de
él de la Florida ustedes lo acaban de
escuchar ha dicho que bueno que fue por
los jueces que por esto insinuando de
artimaña pero pero se cree que la gente
son bobas y yo entiendo
el colega demócrata que tú no quieres
que yo debata contigo Yo eso lo entiendo
afortunadamente tú no controlas a quien
invitan y yo creo que sí yo quisiera
seguir debatiendo contigo para frenar la
desinformación y las mentiras que estás
diciendo porque busquen hillary Clinton
dijo Donald Trump ganó por
valimir Putin o sea quitarle legitimidad
a
la decisión temprana del pueblo
estadounidense Entonces es increíble
porque ustedes lo acaban de escuchar
ella está diciendo en efecto que la Gran
Victoria
merecida
del gobernador de santis Por qué es el
estado con los índices más favorables en
todo Ok en la economía en la generación
de empleo per cápita uno de los que
menos muertos tuvo durante covid porque
no siguió el dictamen de muchas
políticas fracasadas como en Nueva York
que gracias a Cómo murieron personas por
directrices directamente que él tomó
entonces eh el decir
primero estarme acusando a mí de de
negacionista y después ella negarle el
valor legítimo de los floridanos que
votaron y el merecido tributo de Randy
Santos te demuestra esto Esto es el
paradigma de los demócratas el prototipo
de ahí están negando están jugando un
papel negacionista y me dicen no que no
que que o sea que no lo republicanos los
negacionistas Cid brandy santis es
presidenciable y será un momento sino en
el 2024 iniciará en el 2028 el próximo
presidente de los Estados Unidos me
quedó un minuto para finalizar el
programa hagamos las conclusiones de lo
que sigue entonces y lo que deja esta
jornada electoral rápidamente Julio
como ve usted el futuro de estas dos
cámaras que todavía están en juego no
hay nada dicho todavía cómo lo vio usted
para el cierre rápidamente
la cámara baja los republicanos tendrán
control no un control tan amplio en un
margen tan amplio Como hubiera querido y
en la cámara alta en el senado pienso
que también obtendrán una mayoría una
mayoría estrecha pero suficiente como
para frenar
la carrera
hacia la izquierda radical del actual
presidente
[Música]
otras palabras de desinformación el
programa de Joe biden y Joey de toda su
vida no es de
izquierda los republicanos han
sembrado y manipulado está esta
narrativa con mucho efecto en el estado
de Florida yo les felicito a los que
ganaron en la Florida es fundamental
para la democracia pero todavía tenemos
que ver lo que va a pasar en los tres
estados que mencionamos antes y en
particular en Nevada muy interesante por
la presencia de latinos y latinas merece
otro programa otro debate pero yo tengo
mucha confianza en que los los
funcionarios de las elecciones en sí van
a defender su cargo profesionalismo y su
técnico Y entonces vamos a tener que
esperar lo que
ruego Es que
encontremos la forma de de dejar de usar
desinformación acerca de por ejemplo
para los años adelante ella ella y
acepto esto Julio Muchísimas gracias por
este análisis para la audiencia de
France 24 es todo por el momento En
nombre del equipo Les agradecemos su
sintonía la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Giovanni agudelo y la
producción de invitados a cargo de Tania
Herrera sigan dejando sus comentarios en
las redes sociales
[Música]